first to face possible elimination
our French winners wynjym fields head
chef and owner Colin is aiming for the
ultimate fine dining experience
he's created a luxurious dining room and
serves exquisite food but I thought
Colin was trying too hard
overloading his diners with too many
appetizers and too many waiters 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 boot anymore look how
are you guys
just check there's no one in here I
don't know with their place in the final
at stake I've since sent in another
secret diner Rob Alison and expert
foodie with a critical eye and I've sent
all my semi-finalists their own copy of
the footage so that they know what I'm
judging them on this is our second
appetizer amuse-bouche and sometimes
these little touches get too much and
I've ordered my meal I want my long
students I've told Colin endless times
less is more and here we go again
thank you perfect thank you
this looks how's it delicious but it's
not mine
really perfectly cooked long steamed
beautiful
I'm the mixer funny to start I mean
disaster I mean it happens probably one
percent of the time and guess what it's
him
yeah it's just not good enough next to
face undercover scrutiny are Indian
winners Prasad from Bradford mom Cal she
and daughter know me now produce some of
the best food I've ever eaten and it's
all vegetarian delicious one mouthful of
that I feel like I'm back in Mumbai now
I can't leave that to waste I gotta eat
some more than sorry Jesus son Bobby
runs front-of-house with charm and wolf
Sheryl farmer is a food expert with 20
years experience I'm expecting her to
love this place as much as I did but
when she went in undercover Bobby wasn't
anywhere to be seen
instead another member of staff was
running front of house painting the
miles ripped up to go back to I go back
to his cooking be nice to being offered
a drink at that the pie wasn't it nobody
asking the secret diner for drinks and
they're just left alone I mean this
doesn't even look like the same
restaurant
given soundproofing on the kitchen it's
nice to a kind of chatter in the
background but you'll hear people
scraping the files out you can hear this
kitchen porter
by the sound of things beating the hell
out of these plans cleaning this looks
like completely different restaurant
really look like it was them other
dishes were really nicely spiced my
secret diners love the food thank God
because they're not enjoying the service
gunas going to absolutely crucify me
it's about getting it right every time
the contrast from that footage and
compares the wire I received last time
it's nothing don't